There's a three minute and 20 ish second
long scene in the middle of the animated
Saifai Action Thriller Ghost in the
Shell.
It doesn't really qualify as Saifai
action or thriller.
It's a sequence of 34 gorgeous,
exquisitely detailed atmospheric shots
of a future city in Japan that's modeled
after Hong Kong and I'm tempted to make
an hour long video dissecting each shot
individually,
but I really want to look at what this
interlude accomplishes as a whole by
itself and in the context of the film
and its themes.
The first thing to note is that this
montage is full of what Scott mccloud
has called aspect to aspect transitions.
Mccloud is the author of an absolutely
essential graphic novel on the art and
craft of comics and in it he describes
the kind of panel to panel transitions
that have become popular in different
parts of the world.
In American comics,
for example,
the majority of transitions are action
to action fitting for a goal oriented
culture,
interested in telling stories about goal
oriented characters.
Japanese comics,
on the other hand have the long
featured,
a kind of transition that is really very
rarely seen in the west.
The aspect to aspect transition in which
time is virtually abandoned for the
exploration of space.
These kinds of transitions evoke a mood.
They activate the senses and imagination
and they have a rich tradition in
Japan's use of like and often cyclical
works of art.
The emphasis is on being there instead
of getting there and it's that emphasis
at play in this interlude from ghost.
In the shell though this is animation
and not comics.
The aspect to aspect categorization is I
think pretty accurate.
I mean people and things move in these
frames,
but it's impossible to tell if the shots
are meant to be read as temporarily
sequential and I think it's pretty
obvious that that question is really
just irrelevant.
What director Mamoru Oshii accomplishes
here is to expand and draw attention to
the audience's perception of space in
the film and what kind of space is it?
It's the space of a chaotic
multicultural future city dominated by
the intersections of old and new
structures connected by roads,
canals and technology.
Humans move about like electricity along
these avenues plugged into the body of
the metropolis,
the relationship between body and mind.
Shell and ghost is of course a central
theme of the film which tells the story
of a female Cyborg police officer who
with their team hunts down a notorious
hacker only to discover that he's an
incor ai who wants to merge with her and
create a new higher life form.
Since most bodies in this future world
or at least partly artificial people
locate their identities in their ghosts
or their minds,
but with the troubling knowledge that
these also can be hacked.
Memory identity and humanity are all
calling into question.
All your memories about your wife and
daughter are false.
They're like a dream.
Someone's taken advantage of you.
So how can a meditation on space
illuminate the problem and theme of
identity in Ghost in the shell?
Well,
maybe the first thing we should say is
that spaces like identities are
constructed though space often feels
neutral or given like we could move
anywhere within it.
Our movements,
our activities,
our life is always limited by the way
space is produced in most places,
but especially in big cities that
production is controlled not by the
people,
but by gigantic moneyed interests,
state governments or both.
And the same is true for identity spaces
and identities are constructed and not
always by ourselves.
In this respect,
Hong Kong was the perfect city to model
for this film.
It's a city layered with histories and
cultural memory.
Believe it or not,
when ghost in the shell came out in
1995,
it was still a colony or territory of
the United Kingdom.
It had two years left on a 99 year lease
signed in 18,
98,
which was interrupted during the second
world war by a four year occupation by
Japan now was about to be handed back to
communist China with which it had little
relation in both politics and economy.
So who were the Hong Kong people
supposed to be?
Then indeed,
how to define identity was and is a
vital question in the postcolonial world
as the old empires faded,
but left their centuries of subjugation
and influence in the streets and minds
of multicultural cities like Hong Kong
and its inhabitants.
You don't want to maintain the often
racist identities imposed on you by the
colonizers,
but you really can't go back to what you
were before
either.
You're talking about redefining my
identity.
I want to guarantee that I can still be
myself.
There isn't one.
Why would you wish to change in a
dynamic environment?
Your effort to remain what you are is
what limits you.
Look closely
at the city and you can see these
dilemmas played out in space.
Cyber punk has always featured these
uneasy composites of multiple cultures.
These are not utopias,
but they don't have to be imagined as
dystopias either.
The philosopher Michel Foucault called
spaces like this,
Heterotopia,
places that exist in a dynamic state of
layered and changing meanings.
Heterotopia is don't succumb to those
forces that try to make everything the
same.
They are marginal spaces for the
voiceless to construct identities for
themselves.
Cyber punks,
great radical hope with that the
blending of man and machine would have
the same effect on personal identity
that multicultural cities like Hong Kong
would have on collective identity.
It would break down the constructs of
gender and race and class that have
defined us for so long without our say.
You can see that hope in the main
character of ghost in the shell.
The three minute aspect to aspect
interlude in the middle of this film by
its strong break from the rhythm of the
plot forces us to consider the parallels
between city and body,
network and ghost to drive this home.
The rest of the film is framed with
characters set against the city they
live in.
Yes,
spaces are made by humanity,
but humanity is made by its spaces too.
It's a feedback loop.
A cycle made virtuous or vicious based
on the choices we make together.
Ghost in the shell wants to show us that
the dynamics of ourselves and our spaces
are one in the same.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and welcome to
everybody who came in from last week's
children of men video.
The response was absolutely nuts,
so thanks for spreading it around.
I wanted to say thank you because this
is actually the 10th video that I've
made since I started to produce the nerd
writer full time and it's been an
incredible 10 weeks and it's all because
of you guys supporting me on Patrion.
Um,
it wouldn't be possible without you
guys.
I know some of you do it to get the
rewards mugs and stickers,
but most of you do it because you
believe in this kind of relationship
between creator and audience.
And I really do too.
There's nothing between us.
There's nothing between me and you and I
think that's really a model for the
future.
So thank you for supporting me on
Patrion.
I'm about $850 a video now.
I want to try to get it to a thousand
dollars.
That's the big video just to make this
financially feasible.
Um,
there's more rewards coming next week.
There's probably going to be a google
hangout with me,
so if you are a patron,
a patron checked on the messages for
that and I'll let you know when it is.
Thank you again.
I will see you guys next Wednesday.